what is going on everybody welcome to
part 2 of our NLT K or natural language
toolkit tutorial video with Python in
this video we're going to be talking
real briefly about stop words so what
are stop words so with a lot of data
analysis you're going to find that
before you actually get to do any of the
good stuff you're going to have to do a
lot of pre-processing and arguably
that's basically what NLT Kay the module
does help you with
so NLT Kay is not going to you know
generate any insights for you really all
it's going to be able to do is help you
kind of analyze pull apart text tag
things either part of speech named ND
and so on that kind of stuff but it can
also help you with the topic we're gonna
be talking about today and that stop
words so what are stop words so there's
kind of like two notions of what stop
words can be one stop words can be
something that just like you literally
you you come across that word and you
just run away you give it up and you
like leave so a lot of times people
might use words that are typically used
sarcastically as a stop word because
they don't want to continued attempting
to analyze something when it may or may
not be the actual like opposite meaning
so that's one notion but another notion
of stop words these words that you just
pull out you just don't care about them
they're fluff and you don't need them so
this would be like a the and for the
most part these kinds of things don't
really have any meaning to your text
therefore you can just remove them
they're filler words basically and they
make our language to us make a lot more
sense but as far as data analysis is
concerned they're useless so let's go
ahead and get started there so first of
all we're going to go ahead and do from
NLT que corpus again making huge use of
corpus Ruby you'll find that we're using
corpus throughout this entire series I
highly suggest you check it out later on
will actually go visit the corpus and
see all the stuff that we have any way
from NLT que corre corpus imports stock
words
then from NLT k tokenize we're going to
import word underscore tokenize now we
need to make an example sentence so
let's just say example sentence equals
um this is an example showing off stop
word filtration that may or may not work
we'll see hopefully there's enough in
there that will be good so now we're
going to say stop underscore words
equals and we're going to say the set of
stop words dot words and the stop words
has a few languages we're going to be
using the English language so all of our
stop words is going to be beta set of
English stop words that have already
been predefined by n ltk we don't have
to do anything about that now you can
add your own words you can append words
to stop words and so on so for example
let's just print I don't believe it's a
huge set here let's just print them and
see what it is right so here are your
stop words it's a set of them got whom
between yourself if so own you or so
it's actually not that big of a list but
these are just really really common
English words you could probably figure
out a good list of stop words by pulling
up any of those big corpora and using
you know from collections import counter
and then taking every single word adding
it to a big list and using counter and
like the first I don't know 20 words are
probably stock words because they're
just useless so anyway those are stop
words and those are the stop words
rather but now let's show like what we
can do with them so let's tokenize the
sentence so let's do words the equals
word dot our upward underscore oh my
goodness
holy I'm crazy over to underscore
tokenize and what do we want to word
tokenize example sentence so that's it
so now we have the words and then now
we're going to filter the sentence so
filtered underscore sentient I keep on
to put D there sentence so filtered
sentence is we'll just have an empty
list for now and then we're just going
to say for W in words or actually yet
words for W in words if W not in stop
words filtered sentence stock up append
W okay simple enough there is a quick
one liner I'll show you after this that
most people use from examples with NLT K
but it's confusing if you don't know
those one-liners so I'll show you that
in a moment though so we'll save and run
that and we're not printing the
filtering sentence and I think it's
happening afterwards print and filtered
sentence paste that in there okay this
so is an was removed this example
showing off was removed stopped word
filtration period okay so you can see
that at least a few were removed
arguably showing off off maybe should
have remained because we were at select
showing off is almost like a you know a
conjoined pair there but arguably now
the sentence meaning still remains the
same this is this example showing stop
word filtration totally fine so that's
just a quick quick example of now as
promised I'll show you the one-liner I
tend to stay away from those fancy
one-liners just because people don't
really understand what's happening and
then this is really simple to follow
along but I'll show you to you anyways
so you could say instead of this let's
comment that out you could say filtered
underscore sentence equals
so this will be will use the same
parameters W for W in words if not W in
stop words okay so hopefully if I speak
it out slowly and obviously you see
exactly what's happening here but this
is just word for word in words so that's
just iterating through and allowing us
to throw in this down here so for each
word in words if not W so W isn't in
stop words then it's part of the
filtered sentence list that we're making
and then we can just at the end of this
print filtered Oh step D again man a
filtered sentence and there you have
same thing okay so that's stopped words
you'll find that it's useful especially
if you're having any sort of database
you're pulling out words and you're say
you have like articles on articles on
articles stacks on stacks um starts uh
this will save you a lot of processing
time de not waste your time with words
that just simply do not matter so
anyways that's it for stop words we'll
go ahead and stop they're not too
interesting but also pretty helpful to
have nonetheless if you do have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support of subscriptions until the next
video